we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P now I
actually don't know what this person's
talking about see if you can understand
what it is that they're referring to
take a listen David Pakman don't you
think abortion is going to be the key
issue that destroys the Democratic
coalition come November thank you I
don't know what they mean I mean in the
sense that the Democratic coalition
first of all the country more than ever
approves of abortion in most cases the
country more than ever believes that
abortion should be legal in most cases
at a higher rate than at any point in
history since the roe v wade era that's
number one number two I didn't think
that there was really much debate about
this on the Democratic side so I don't
know what the caller is referring to I
also don't even think abortion is really
going to be a big issue as we get into
November very often you know in general
election debates there will be questions
about Supreme Court justices would you a
would you nominate anyone to the court
that might overturn roe v wade or just
support for roe v wade a figure as a
prerequisite for anybody you would
recommend to the court nominate to the
court I don't see abortion playing a
large role here at all and I genuinely
don't know what the caller is talking
about so I'd love to hear from you what
do you think they're referring to make
sure that you are signed up to the David
Pakman show
newsletter you can sign up at david
pakman.com Thursday April 9 one-day
membership special we lost three hundred
and eighty nine members in March because
of the virus and people tightening the
belt we've lost a few dozen already in
April April ninth we're doing a one-day
membership special biggest discount of
the year to try to recover some of those
lost members sign up at david pakman.com
for my newsletter you'll be notified at
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time on Thursday and
of course don't miss today's bonus show
with producer pat joining us from his
second location in two weeks after a big
ceiling implosion took place last week
we told that story and Pat is with us
from another this
a secured undisclosed location will
speak to you on the bonus show